esta comida es para los migrantes
proviene de una empresa que la prepara
en una fábrica una vez a la semana
cocina para nosotros recogemos la comida
preparada y la distribuimos cada dia
flavius y lyon y sus equipos se
movilizan para ayudar a los migrantes
estamos en los suburbios de timisoara
una de las principales ciudades de
rumanía en el oeste del país
y aquí desde noviembre estos nuevos
exiliados son cada vez más numerosos
flavio se está en todos los frentes
algunos de ustedes duermen aquí si vino
la policía de nuevo ha venido o yo no lo
oí no
wisin & yandel
esta asociación es la única en timisoara
que presta asistencia a los inmigrantes
con el apoyo de la sociedad civil les
ofrece la única comida caliente del día
la mayoría son afganos
han huido de la guerra y la violencia en
su país
no se arrepienten de haber pasado por
rumanía
es muy difícil intentar atravesar
croacia
allí la policía nos repele y nos aleja
aquí es más fácil es fácil aquí en
rumanía si este camino es muy fácil sí
pero no nos quedaremos mucho tiempo por
el endurecimiento de la seguridad en las
vecinas serbia y croacia se ha
convertido rumanía en una nueva ruta
migratoria en los balcanes hacia europa
occidental
flavio se está convencido de ello
después de haber trabajado nueve años
con solicitantes de asilo
afirma que timisoara nunca ha vivido una
situación semejante en 2020 nuestro país
registró más de 6.200 solicitudes de
asilo se trata de un récord histórico en
nuestro país
y por supuesto tiene que ver con las
nuevas rutas migratorias porque la
mayoría de los migrantes ya no pueden
pasar por croacia nunca antes en
timisoara habíamos visto a migrantes
durmiendo en las calles oa migrantes de
tan solo 14 o 15 años durmiendo en
edificios abandonados es realmente algo
nuevo sin estar preparada para una
afluencia masiva de inmigrantes
rumanía dispone de muy poco espacio de
alojamiento los solicitantes de asilo
duermen donde pueden como en este
edificio abandonado y en condiciones
sanitarias especialmente difíciles sobre
todo en tiempos de pandemia dormimos
aquí y encima cuando viene la policía
nos castiga nos dice no tienen derecho a
estar aquí
asensio
miren esto es un problema real
un problema que la alcaldía podría
haberse evitado
dice estar abrumada y buscar el apoyo
del gobierno que aún no llega
en timisoara estamos al límite de lo
manejable pero si las llegadas aumentan
rumanía tendrá que reconsiderar su
enfoque el gobierno de bucarest debe
asumir sus responsabilidades y no dejar
todo el peso en las autoridades locales
mientras tanto la ong de flavius
gestiona la emergencia
incluso cuando están aislados como este
iraquí que no quiere que nadie sepa
dónde se esconde
compramos cosas leche pollo café fruta y
me puedes decir que después de dos o
tres días podemos traerte más cosas
gracias amigos gracias de nada
al principio quería ir a alemania pero
la policía me lo impidió
con árboles
quizá intenté quedarme aquí porque la
gente me parece agradable y servicial
al y el solicitante de asilo iraquí es
una excepción la mayoría de los
migrantes esperan continuar su viaje
hacia europa occidental a través de la
vecina hungría